Thank you all for joining in.
My name is uh Gurrinder Raju,
and I'm gonna be talking to you today about
how workspaces is powering the future.
Of work
And I'll be joined by a great cast of uh
speakers. I'll be joined by Ray,
who's gonna talk about what's new in workspaces
and what are the
newer capabilities that we added to the product.
That you should be excited about and incorporating
in your workload?
I'll be joined by uh
Cody from Deloitte who is gonna talk
about.
How Deloitte uses workspaces at
scale,
and how workspaces enables Deloitte
to meet the needs of
multiple different personas.
And uh I'll be joined by
uh Robert Green from Vision,
who's gonna talk about how Vision
is using, using multiple
workspace intelligence features
to build agentic capabilities
and boost the productivity of their
end users and admits.
And towards the end, I'll come back to
the future of work and uh
have a discussion with you on what are the patterns
that are changing,
and what is that we are building to
define and drive the future of work.
Uh, you don't want to miss that out. Um.
And if you stay a little bit longer, I'll
be around to answer any of the questions and
maybe show you a cool couple demo demo
or two to see that what's cooking.
All of you have been going through an unprecedented
pace of change, and it's a little bit unique
to end-user computing because it's at the intersection
of so many things.
Computing, virtualization,
cybersecurity, data center exits,
agentic AI, you know,
uh, agents, frontier agents, productivity,
right? And uh.
I can relate to, I met
so many customers that we talked about there's just
too much changing,
right? And uh
let's pick up the first change
from this unprecedented pace of changes that you have
been tackling, which is the
increase in
On-premise virtualization software.
2X, 3X,
5X, 10X, in many cases more,
and this is creating real pressure on you to
accelerate the exit
of the data centers that you might still have
some workloads running in.
It doesn't stop there.
You have been tackling major
life cycle
events both on software,
operating system versions
and hardware versions.
And
it's very time-consuming and expensive,
especially when it gets coupled with
The, uh, the cost unpredictability
that I talked about in the previous slide.
Keeps going,
you know,
Agentic AI is accelerating
across the entire industry and,
uh,
as you heard in Matt's keynote
and also Andy commented about it
is we at Amazon
believe that it's gonna
yield and deliver remarkable results.
And I see that in my own team, my
product and engineering teams.
Uh,
and have incorporated that in their daily work, and I'm
loving the increased pace that I
see on a daily basis.
All of you are being asked by your leaders
to incorporate agentic AI.
So you are tackling this along with
the OS life cycle version events
and the
cost and predictability.
With great power comes great responsibility,
right? Like with the agentic AI increase, you
are having to tackle a
new
surface area of uh threat
vectors,
you know, um,
prompt injection.
Many of your
end users, many of your employees knowingly,
unknowingly,
you know,
uh, leaking some of your confidential
information to chatbots or other
online GII tools, and
it's not good.
So you're having to rethink the tools you
use
to tackle these, right? Um,
it's a lot of
changes that you're adapting to.
I, I, I wanna show, do
a show of hands, right? Like, on how many of
you actually relate to it. Yeah, yeah, you're telling
me the story. That's how
my last 12 months or 18 months have been. Just
do a show of hands.
You know
Many hands showing up and then you're not
alone, you know, and I'll chat
with you, I'll talk about on how workspaces
is enabling you to navigate the, the space
of change
uh with the capabilities uh
uh that we have.
Before I do that, I'll just quickly refresh
your
mind about the portfolio of products
that we have under the Workspaces brand.
You have a full virtual desktop
available to you,
persistent, non-persistent.
You have uh application
only virtualization.
We have our own purpose-built streaming protocol
that we obsess on and keep investing in
to deliver a delightful end user experience.
We have thin client devices
for lightweight endpoints.
We have a secure browser. If all your end users
use SAS applications, it's a great option for
you. And then of course, uh,
you know, beyond all the.
Uh, native products that we have,
we also give you the capability with the
Workspace's core to bring your preferred
end user and admin experience,
uh,
to Workspace's infrastructure.
Let's go through one by one, a little more detail, right?
Start with desktops. Workspaces gives
you the option of Windows and operating,
Windows and Linux operating system choices.
Client OS, server OS,
we have the broadest selection of Linux flavors
across any cloud provider.
Um,
And then you can use them in multiple
configurations.
Tuning and tuning it for the workload
that you have with the persistent desktop,
with non-persistent desktop.
You can.
Uh, we are present in, uh, 20 regions
and counting. Over the next 9 to 18
months, you will see
that we'll be globally expanding, which means
that any new region that AWS launches
will also be present
at the day of the launch or soon after.
Uh,
We support the different identity choices
that, uh, you know, and then you can pick the identity
choice, whether it's a cloud directory or it's
a, uh, on-premise
directory,
and then we give you the option of a variety of bundle
sizes, whether it's storage, compute,
networking, and you can tune it to the needs that you have.
Um,
We support multiple differentiating features,
Amazon Global Accelerator, which routes
the end user traffic to the Amazon fiber as
quickly as possible,
and we have multi-region resiliency,
which gives you options for business
continuity and have a real tangible
disaster recovery plan.
So between persistent and non-persistent desktops,
varied bundle sizes,
global region availability and flexible identity
choices,
it's a very versatile, scalable
desktop infrastructure for you.
Let's move to application streaming. Not
everyone needs the full desktop experience.
Not one of your
end users need a start menu,
and many of your end users just work on a
select set of applications,
and
you can, you can use you can
use Workspace's applications,
previously called AppStream,
to give them an app-only experience and.
Tens of thousands of our customers
have used this to sacsify
their native applications
and make them instantly accessible
to their end users all over the world,
just like a web app, right?
And this model helps with the distribution
challenge.
No more complex software installations,
right, like a native app applications
become available just like
a URL.
Again, I talked about the disparate protocol.
Delightful end user experience is super important,
and this is the backbone of all the products
and services that you see here,
and we continue making foundational
investments.
This is our in-house,
our own DCV protocol.
We also give you choices for thin clients,
not only our own thin client, but from partners
as well, and then this gives you the option
to decouple
the operating system from the
client device.
You can have a powerful desktop in
the cloud, and then you can have a very lightweight
thin client device.
I talked about the uh the secure browser.
This is this is very compelling,
and over time we have innovated on
very persona specific solutions,
right, and
secure browser starts at $7 a user
a month and for your end users
who are
primarily using SAS applications, this is
a great, great choice.
And of course,
All the other capabilities that I talked about.
We also give you the choice of bringing
your own preferred admin and end user
experience, and then make it run in the cloud
on AWS
and Workspace's reliant infrastructure.
So in summary, you get a comprehensive
toolkit of solutions.
Continue moving then, you know, how does
it talk, how does it help
solve the challenges that we talked about earlier,
you know. Workspace's
core gives you
access of the complete feature
set of your partner,
you know, and um
You can bring your workload without
changes. So if you're getting pressure from your
leadership to accelerate data
center exit, this is a great, great tool
for you. Talked
about OS Lifecycle, hundreds
of thousands of end users are running
already on Windows 11
workspaces in the cloud on our services,
and uh
across the workspaces, pools and personal, both.
So,
we've enabled
these.
End users to onboard onto Windows 11
with our in-built migrate APIs,
moving from a previous version to a new version,
and many of these customers actually continue relying
on their previous hardware,
moving their full powered desktop to the
cloud
by keeping and keeping their endpoint and
client devices very simple.
Agentic AI accelerated agentic AI
adoption, right?
We, behind the scenes
have built
multiple
Intelligence capabilities, many of them
are visible to you, many of them are not visible to you,
and uh customers are leveraging
them. You'll see an example of that later today
when uh
when Vision talks about how they are using it to build Agentic
AI capabilities.
And then last, new cybersecurity
threat vector
surface that has emerged.
And then uh just to give you an example,
like a defense agency in Asia Pacific
rolled out secure browser to the tens of
thousands of users,
you know, to protect themselves against
threats like prompt injection and
uh you know, unintentional
leakage of data
through any of the chat chat,
you know, chatbots and GAI tools.
Pixel streaming gives you
ephemeral access to the browser,
which is completely isolated from the client
device,
and it gives you great protection against these
cybersecurity threats.
These are not the only challenges we help you with.
We have been innovating for a decade.
And uh, you know.
Innovating
by
introducing new pricing models.
Workspaces when GA in 2014, we launched
the RE model soon after that,
and uh we give you continued and
increased selection of both client OS,
server OS, Linux choices,
you know, and uh
as I said, we keep innovating based
upon the persona.
One size does not fit all, and we don't
want you to overprovision. To that, we launched
Tapstream in 2016,
and we launched uh Secure Browser
uh somewhere late 2020, 2021.
The pace is only accelerating.
You know, and if you look at the last 3 years,
there are so many favorite features that I have
that I've been very, very deeply,
uh, connected to in launching, right?
The selection keeps on increasing. We have
launched new versions of Linux, Rocky, Ral,
Ubuntu, launched uh Multi-region
Resilience,
Amazon Global Accelerator for faster,
uh, you know, end user
experience.
And we launched Workspace's core.
A conferencing is optimized
across all major vendors.
What does it mean?
With this accelerated pace of innovation, we,
AWS is recognized as a leader in desktop
as a service by Gartner for the 2nd year in
a row,
you know, and uh
it's a
I would say it's a great testimonial to our capabilities
and obsession and our continued
perseverance in innovating in this area
for the last 10 years.
With that,
I will hand over to Ray, who will
go through some of these newer features in a bit
more detail.
And uh
thank you, Ray.
Thank you, thank you, Grinder.
All right. Hello. Good afternoon,
everyone. My name is Rai
Wang.
I lead one of the product management
teams in Amazon workspaces
focusing on end user experience.
So today, I'm excited to share
with you uh some of the
uh recent launches that we
made this year.
Uh, you know, Amazon workspaces,
uh, service customers across different
industry segments,
right? So from assembly lines
to the trading floor, from hospitals
to the, uh, uh, government
agencies,
workspaces has become
the trusted solution for many
of our customers across a diverse
set of cases.
We're always looking to hear from
you and learn from our customers
about their unique needs.
So even after this session, we'll be happy
to talk to you about your needs,
how we can iterate on workspaces
to, to uh meet your needs better.
Right. As you can see from here,
organizations of all sizes
trust workspaces with their desktop
and application streaming needs.
These logos represent more
than just customers to us.
To us, they're our partners
in innovation, right?
They help us to continue to
refine workspaces
to meet the evolving demands
of uh enterprise,
uh, modern
work, workplaces.
All right. So let's talk about our 2025
launches, right? 2025
has been a great year for our workspaces.
We made some headways across
security, performance, and usability.
All right, let's start, let's dive into
a few areas where we made some strides
this year. Let's
start with delivering
delightful end user experience.
what does that mean, right?
A delightful end user experience
to us means that the virtual desktops
and or the application should feel very responsive
and natural, just like the physical
one. If a user
can use their local laptop
to do something,
we feel like they should be able to do
the exact same thing, maybe even better
with their workspaces,
even under challenging network
conditions. So this
year, you know, to deliver this delightful
end user experience,
we first improved our peripheral
support. We launched generic
USB redirection for
some to help users use some of these
common uh USB devices
such as
payment devices or uh
uh barcode scanners
that takes care of a variety of use
cases that have peripheral needs.
We also added support for
webau redirection,
uh, which allows users to use
security keys such as UBKs
or even Windows Hello
within their workspaces session.
And in addition, we have collaborated
with Wacom,
the industry's leading
professional drawing tablet maker.
Uh, to give professional
artists such as, uh,
visual effects artists or,
uh,
yeah, different professional artists,
uh, a way to use Wacom
tablets and all the special features they
have in their Wacom tablets, plus
their Wacom pens all within
their workspaces seamlessly
under ultra low latency, right?
So this is something called Wacom Bridge
that uh we have launched with them.
Uh,
in addition,
right, for audio and video workloads
like web conferencing,
we have collaborated closely with
Microsoft this year
to launch a public preview
of Teams
optimization for VDI.
This feature offloads the
team's audio and video packets
from
the remote workspaces host
to your local client and
significantly reduces the CPU and memory
consumption.
In addition to that, we also
improved international keyboard support.
Now, with special
languages like Hebrew or languages
with dead keys,
users can seamlessly type
whatever they want in their workspaces.
And lastly, we launched a feature called
client auto update.
This makes it super easy for
users to get the latest features
and security updates from workspaces
without any
administrative intervention.
All right.
On the networking,
networking front,
uh, we also integrated with
Amazon Global Accelerator,
so AGA.
Uh, this dramatically improves
connection stability and performance
worldwide across the globe.
This means fewer dropped connections,
more
smooth streaming experience, and
more consistent end user experience.
Even for remote workers living
in like challenging
network environments.
The second major, major area of
innovation for us is um
global selection and presence.
Our customers have told us that
they would like more flexibility,
especially regarding the compute
and storage options associated
with workspaces, right?
So they want to use the latest and greatest
from EC2 instances
that can exactly match their
applications need while keeping the cost
in check.
So this year,
we're happy to announce that we're, we have launched
175 new
instance types for workspaces
applications. Uh,
including the latest compute
optimized, memory optimized,
and accelerated instance types.
For storage,
we also increase to up to
500 gigabytes of desk storage,
up from 200.
And most importantly,
we launched a new feature that allows
you to import your own image
to workspaces applications.
A lot of our customers have told us that
they uh have their own golden image
CICD pipeline or they have
their custom tools that helps them
to maintain the freshness of those
image and keeps them updated.
Now you can keep all of
uh image pipelines
and then export those when you're ready
and import them into workspaces
applications. This greatly reduces
the manual operational efforts that
admins
had to do previously to use workspaces
applications. Lastly,
we also introduced 4 new
regions
support, which brings the total number
of regions across the globe to 20
for workspaces applications.
And that's not all, right? So global
presence and selection is also important
for the customers that want to use our
partner solutions like Citrix
DS with workspace's infrastructure.
So this year,
we launched a new feature called Workspace's
core Managed Instances.
Uh, With this, this
greatly simplified VDI
deployment for these kind of customers,
allowing them to use highly customizable
instance configurations,
including almost all the EC2
instance types that you can think of,
right? And they can do it all
within the security and governance
um boundaries of their uh
own AWS account.
So this is great news for those
customers as well.
All right.
And lastly,
another area of focus for us this
year is with our secure browser
product. For secure browser,
we first made significant
performance improvements in session
start time.
Uh, we, uh, up to 50%
more, uh, faster, reducing
the friction of launching secure browser
session, sessions.
You know, our new two-bar configurability
also allows organizations to customize
the user experience,
uh, while maintaining security control,
right? We also launched CloudWatch
metrics for secure browser,
allowing the admins,
giving them the visibility they need
to, uh, into the
customer um end user usage
patterns and also potentially
security events.
Most importantly,
On the security front,
we also introduced three
features this year,
inline reduction for sensitive
content, web content filtering,
and session logging.
These, uh, combination of
these
three features allowed IT admins
to maintain control over the
potential data exfiltration,
uh,
uh, risks.
All right. With that, I will
hand it over to Corey
from Deloitte to talk about how
they leverage these workspaces innovations
for different personas in Deloitte.
All right, thanks, Ray.
Hello, my name's Corey Weeden. I'm a senior
cloud engineer at Deloitte. Oh, there it is.
Um, I work primarily on our VDI team
supporting our AWS workspaces environment.
Today I wanna talk to you about our journey
to workspaces.
So let's start with who are we, right?
Some of you guys are probably coming from Fortune 500
companies, maybe uh, a US
based company, um, maybe even you're coming
from Deloitte.
Um, but there's probably a good chance either
way that you've probably come across the green dot
at some point,
right? And why is that? It's because
nearly 90%
of Fortune 500 companies trust Deloitte, and
we are also supporting over 8500
US based firms.
Right. So Deloitte employs
about 180,000, maybe more
US employees all around the world.
So with that, there's a need for virtual desktops.
So what did it look like before we had workspaces?
Well, our team was supporting 7 on-prem
environments, right? And if you have, or if you've
had an on-prem VDI environment, you're
probably familiar with some of the challenges, right?
Operational overhead, hardware
that you have to manage yourself, doing your own
OS upgrades, server patching, compliance,
you name it, right?
And our personal favorite, the chargeback
model, right? What does that look like? How do we charge
our users?
Do we just give them a flat rate?
Do we try and estimate,
you know, if you don't know what your environment's gonna look
like in 6 to 12 months, how do you estimate
how much each machine costs,
right? So
then
There it is in, uh, 2020, right? COVID
hits.
And everyone gets sent home,
right? But not only are people now working from
home, we still have our new hires that are being on boarded.
We also have our intern programs that are still running.
We also have just your everyday break fix
situations.
So how do we do that
when we have a supply chain bottleneck
when it's hard to get physical assets, right?
So we needed a lot of virtual desktops, and we
needed them quickly,
right? So in comes workspaces, right? A
fully managed service that we could use
to scale out seamlessly
and quickly.
With workspaces,
we didn't have to worry about the, the
hardware management, right? We don't have to do our own server
patches or upgrades or anything like that anymore,
and we don't have to worry about how much space are we
gonna need in 6 months or how quickly can
we rack and stack more hardware to get that space
available.
Amazon handles that for us, right?
So Workspaces give us the ability to scale
up, scale out, and we can do it globally
across 8 regions, all from the same pane,
all in the same console,
right? But
who, who uses workspaces,
right? At the way we have a lot of different personas,
we have a lot of different types of people using,
uh, workspaces, you know, from your daily task
worker or maybe it's an executive who just
needs to log in to check their email or maybe join a
Teams call,
right? Maybe we have project teams that are
using workspaces for their contractors.
Maybe they don't have time to ship a laptop
across the globe to get their
contract work and they need to start work today.
We also have a lot of developers who are using
workspaces as their secure development
environment, right? So we give them a full-blown
8 CPU machine and they can have their
own development environment.
Our, how, how can we deploy
all these machines so quickly, right? In the
heart of COVID when everyone needs a virtual machine
right away,
our development teams were able to
create a self-service provisioning
process to where no matter where you are in the world
or whatever time in the world it is, you
didn't have to wait for the US team to
wake up or submit a ticket and
wait for the ticketing process to get a workspace,
you could deploy your own machine.
And at the heart of COVID, I think our team was
supporting north of 15,000 workspaces,
but that was just for personal.
Today our team is supporting workspaces personal,
secure browser,
and even pooled, and that just gives us the
ability to fulfill even more use cases
across the
company.
And in in partnership with AWS
we've we've come up with a simpler
workflow, a smoother workflow to create
and manage our existing workspace
images,
and that's helped us in a couple areas
like our Windows 11 migration and
onboarding Ubuntu workspaces for our Linux
friends. We've also
started exploring
a simpler authentication flow, a,
a more modern identity alignment with
tra ID workspaces.
We have enhanced observability with Project
Hawkeye,
and of course, if you haven't heard about it
already, we're trying, we are exploring
the capabilities of workspaces
and how we can develop, enhance and optimize
the next
AI capability,
right? And so with that,
I will turn it over to Gariner.
Thank you, Cody. Thank you.
As you can see, this is my favorite slide, right?
I'm incorporating it for the 2nd time. Like,
I like this so much because this, you know, shows
and presents the work of the team.
It shows the accelerated pace
of what we are doing for our customers
and how it enables customers like Deloitte to
leverage our solutions and meet the needs
of demanding needs of different
personas that they take care of, right?
So I talked about how we started early
on, kinda, you know, introducing new pricing
models, uh, newer selection,
and, uh, uh, you know, newer
solutions
for each price to performance point
and different personas that you need workspaces, secure
browser, application,
uh, streaming with uh with AppStream.
And since then, the kind of pace has accelerated,
right? Like identity choices, networking,
uh, features, and user features,
enabling you to, you know,
uh, use cloud Directory, multi-region resilience,
uh, AGA.
There are 4
features in here that I like to particularly
call out, right? If you see kind of
the dancing
boxes, right, like, I think those are the
4 that I'll call out, which kind of gives
me a good segue into the next section.
These four features are Workspace's
core,
when we launched it in, uh, like I
think 3 years ago, around kind of 2022,
and enabling you to bring your
M365 applications onto
workspaces, the entire workspace's suite
of products.
The third one is the image onboarding
improvements that we've done where
we use AI behind the
scenes to self-heal
a lot of the issues that might be
there in the image that would have otherwise
required a lot of work
to be done by you.
And we launched Workspace's core
managed instances earlier this year to give you the full
selection of, uh, you know,
uh, your partner feature set and
the best of AWS, right?
Together,
these features help you.
These features
help us to meet you where you are and
accelerate the move from
your on-premise environments
and uh moving on to
cloud-enabled fully
managed solutions, you know, on a, on
a digital workplace. So,
We have multiple partners who have integrated with
Workspace's core, right? Like with Citrix
and Omnisa,
you have, we have coverage and you
have coverage of vast majority of
on-premise workloads,
you know, and uh which you could
migrate to,
uh, you know, the AWSN workspace's
infrastructure.
And with WorkSpot,
LeoStream, and Vision,
this gives you
a fully managed.
Digital workplace solution powered by
workspaces and AWS.
So, the next section
I want to talk to you about is
not only these capabilities, workspace's
native capabilities, workspace's partner
capabilities,
but there's been a lot of innovation
that we and the broader AWS
have collaborated on,
which gives you intelligence capabilities.
Like, so, for example,
AWS has launched multiple MCPs.
Feature set where workspaces, APIs
are already integrated for you to build
agentic solutions. At the same
time,
newer agentic applications
like uh
uh QuickSuite and Quiro
are enabling the customers to build,
uh, you know, and accelerate
uh their own product feature set.
So with that, I will hand it over to Robert
Green, who is the CEO of Vision to talk
about on how they're leveraging these intelligence capabilities
and workspaces broadly
to boost their end user and admin productivity.
Alright, good afternoon.
I'm Rob Green, CEO of Vision. Uh,
today I'm gonna,
uh, show you something with that
will hopefully fundamentally change the way you think
about desktop as a service.
So imagine an AI assistant,
uh, that lives inside your desktop,
one that actually knows you. It knows
your applications,
your workflows, your data,
uh, your history,
not a generic chatbot, a personalized
intelligence that understands your context
and anticipates your needs.
What if
your help desk can answer uh
an issue before the user puts a ticket
in? What if your finance team could
ask a simple question and get detailed cloud
cost breakdown
directly from their desktop?
This isn't science fiction,
this is what
we are working on now.
Oops. Hit
the wrong button.
There we go. Alright,
sorry about that.
So first, a quick intro in vision. Uh, so
we're 14 years old,
um, we, we, we're the only vendor managed
desk, uh, that combines the enterprise desktops,
um, with, uh, instant provisioning.
Uh, we, uh,
you know, traditional VDI, uh, deployments
take about 4 months. Um, we
can deliver,
uh, secure, compliant virtual desktops
in about 4 hours.
That's not an incremental improvement,
that's a paradigm shift.
Our platform is end to end, zero trust
access, always on compliance,
and everything um in, in
between. Built on AWS
purpose built for the enterprise.
So let me give you a quick tour of our product
suite and dive a little bit um into
the AI innovation.
So our philosophy is uh
no assembly required, batteries included.
Uh, so we have a DAS platform
that is your complete virtual desktop infrastructure,
industry leading protocol,
automation, unified management.
Our cloud PC is our persistent,
uh, uh, cloud desktop on AWS,
uh, again built for enterprise grade performance.
Overwatch monitoring, um,
essentially allowing you to be proactive
and no problems before your end users do.
Um, our Halo, uh, browser isolation,
uh, not secure enterprise browser but secure
every browser.
Um, Security Pulse, which is our comp our
continuous compliance automation
for HIPPAA, uh, SOC, as
well as PCI,
and our managed instances which gives us full service
or co-managed, um, again, to,
to flex to meet what you need.
So our new buy now portal is our self-service
deployment that allows you to get to production
uh even faster.
So, um, now here's where it gets
really interesting.
Uh, let, let me show you what we are uh
leveraging Workspace's intelligence to bring
Agenic AI to the desktop.
So we've integrated
workspaces intelligence across 5 key areas.
Uh, each one represents a real
problem that enterprises struggle with today.
And an AI powered solution that's becoming
more and more a reality.
So the first is self-healing image onboarding.
Rapid, reliable, and repeatable process
to onboard your OS image, so you can import
that image that you've been working on, part
of your, your, your, your CICD pipeline
or whatever um you've used in the past.
Uh, flexibility at every uh uh
uh flexibility for your journey.
So that really means uh we support core bundles
and core managed instances, providing flexibility
to use workspaces your way.
Vision's AI cloud PC Ask Ray,
which I'll be talking about more um after
this. Our AI system that lives
inside the desktop,
users can ask questions, get
help, and solve problems without data
ever leaving their desktop.
Our AI powered troubleshooting,
um,
correlating logs, metrics,
and sessions
across across systems takes hours
for normal admins. Ray can do it instantly,
which I will show, uh, here shortly.
And then AI driven cost management,
finance teams want cost visibility. We
give them democratized access.
So here's the secret sauce.
Uh, so we've connected Ray,
uh, to both workspaces and digit MCP
servers.
We're giving Ray full context across
infrastructure and desktop as a service
layers.
Ray isn't a separate tool users
have to, uh, learn. It is embedded
in the desktop experience.
Helping users work smarter, not harder.
Each user gets personalized assistance,
but user A's experience does not
impact user B's experience.
Um, so here's what sets Ray apart
context from every layer. AWS
infrastructure,
workspaces, vision DS,
and the end user's environment.
That's not just data, that's intelligence.
So let me show you what this looks like in, in,
in practice, right?
We'll start with the real world experience.
So, um, everyone's gotten
a support ticket that says, uh,
my desktop is, is, is, is frozen,
right? That's it, no context,
nothing else, my desktop is frozen, and
I've got a very frustrated user.
In the old world, here's what happens.
The tier one asks the user for
more details. The user takes about an hour
or so to get back, and then tier one
escalates it up to tier 2. Tier 2
goes and checks out the logs, um, and
then, you know,
they may find something and they may not. Days
pass, users are still frustrated.
In the Ray world,
Using simple natural language interaction,
Ray goes out, correlates, and, and, and
pulls back from the various
MCP servers across all the layers
with context that talk about session
state, performance metrics, recent changes,
everything, and does that in minutes,
yeah, and not hours.
The user says desktop is freezing. Ray
translates that into a multi-system
uh diagnostic query
that correlates the data and delivers
actionable insights in minutes, not
hours. So
let me double click into it to kind
of show you behind the scenes.
So this is leveraging Quiro as you
can see on the screen.
Um, so it's Monday
morning, users are complaining about slow desktops.
Your admin opens up Overwatch, uh, sees
the graphs, right, opens in, it then
goes to the AWS console,
opens up cloud watch metrics, cross references
with recent changes, looks at network
telemetry. 40 to 60 minutes
later they find a root cause.
Or they can just ask Ray.
Um, and if we look under the hood using Quiro,
you can see the vision, um,
Vision Ray actually goes in and and leverages
both Vision MCP servers and
Workspace's MCP servers to investigate
the root cause. Ray sees everything in the
admin would, um,
would have to correlate manually, but they see it
instantly.
But Ray doesn't just stop at, at, at
correlating data, it finds a solution,
um and um
it prevents the problem from happening in the future.
This is not about replacing admins though. This
is about giving admins a
uh
Iron Man suit,
allowing them to spend more time doing strategic
work versus correlating and troubleshooting.
So now let me show you something that that will
make the finance team happy.
So here's a scenario,
um, it plays out in every enterprise.
Your finance team needs cost breakdown,
um, for their, their cloud spin.
They don't have AWS console access and nor
should they.
Um, so
the, that non-technical user from their
desktop in finance asks a
simple question in natural language,
and Ray connects to the AWS,
uh, and, and Workspace's MCP
servers, pulls the data
and responds with a clear cost breakdown,
uh, with insights.
But here's where it gets really, really
interesting, um.
Ray asks,
do you want me to automate that for you next month?
User says, sure,
and then Ray will automatically generate
a script and ensure that that
report is on his on their desktop
for the next month.
So, seeing is believing. So
I put together a very, very quick video. It's
gonna, it's gonna go by very quickly,
but this is um kind of going over those
three use cases that I just talked about.
So first we're gonna show how Ray
is interact allows users to interact
with their desktop. So interact with their files,
interact
with um asking things about
the files, interacting
um and allowing that user to
pull back data very quickly as well
as open up files.
So, and this is just one use case, Ray can can
do a multitude of things on the desktop
and make and again allow that end
user to have that superpower.
So at the end here it's gonna uh open up
a file. There
you go. So in the second use
case we talked about um you know the finance
use case,
where they, they, the finance non-technical
user in simple language,
ask a question.
And I'm showing you the back end, so obviously this
is kind of showing the verbose mode,
but it goes through, pulls out the data, correlates
the data, creates insights, and
then visualizes it.
And then automatically creates a script to
automate it going forward.
So the final use case is Ray
can take a trouble ticket again,
going back to that, you know, that my desktop
is frozen.
Correlate that to the multiple layers,
so that's the AWS layer, the vision
layer, the workspaces layer, and
actually correlate all the components
that that could go into making up that desktop
for monitoring, Overwatch,
as well as cloudwatch and then pull back
a solution
and the problem,
excuse me, the root cause as well as
the solution in a matter of minutes. Now
this is drastically sped up for our demonstration,
but uh it's still a matter of minutes to get
to the root cause,
and that's my time.
Thank you so much, Rob.
Um,
it's so cool to see.
It's so cool to see vision using workspaces
and broader AWS capabilities and
Kiiro and, uh, you know, like Workspaces
API is integrated into
um
The
AWS MCP servers enabling these capabilities,
enabling these kind of gentic features.
I wanna talk about the future
of work, right? Like,
where are things going?
Uh, and what is workspaces
building to define, drive it, and what
is that you should be thinking about while making
your choices
in how you design
your digital workplace strategy and
shape it, actively shape it.
I want to take you through
how the era of applications has evolved.
So it's a little bit of a sneak preview
or kind of a like a walk back on
how these application frameworks,
desktops started, right? Like the first era
was native applications.
These applications are built in, um,
ah, you know,
uh, like interacting deeply with the operating
system in, uh, languages,
C. You know, or
uh C++.
And there is a very clear boundary
on what's remote, what's local,
and the end user uses a desktop that's
local and connects to either
desktops
or
applications.
This is kind of, uh, I think a
lot of that, you, a lot of it, you will relate
to it. This is the native era
of applications,
right? Um.
These applications had
deep performance capabilities because
you are able to use the operating system,
but you require very
fine-grained management on updating
them, version management of it,
you know, and your end user
is required to install them,
so it's not controlled, distribution is not controlled
by you. How did this evolve?
This evolved into the set of
applications where distribution is a lot easier, right?
Like, uh,
applications are well built with web browser
as the, uh, you know,
As the client, and it
makes your applications accessible to
everybody. Ah, so it solves
the distribution problem.
So SAS transformation has been happening,
but it is still slow,
uh, to the point where, uh,
I think administrators and
decision makers
think about, have to think about,
you know, will I, will I get the same performance,
right? Like if I move to a SAS application.
And there are many deeply entrenched
workflows which kind of slow down this,
this transformation.
While the transformation
or kind of the exhalation to SAS
applications is happening, right? Like a new era of
applications is coming in.
What does it look like?
In this era,
End users, customers will continue using
native applications. They continue using SAS
applications. You're not going to change them overnight,
you know.
Um,
but there are 3 new patterns
that are gonna emerge or
are kind of already emerging.
The first one is in-app agents.
These agents live within the
applications that are already being used, whether
they are native applications or the SAS
applications, right? Like,
this can be an in-app agent on the sidebar,
which has the context of how you're using the
tool, you know, and helps accelerate
the usage.
The second one is
agentic assistant on teammates.
You heard
some of the announcements in Matt's keynote about
uh new frontier agents and teammates
that AAS has launched.
This is a different pattern of
how agentic
usage,
you know, works or agents work
alongside the end user as an assistant,
or they have an independent identity of
their own
as a teammate.
And the third one is born native
Agentic applications.
It's a completely new experience framework,
you know, and uh together,
I would say with these 3 new components,
this is the agentic era of applications,
right? So,
Starting with native applications, transitioning
to SAS applications, and then accelerating
to agentic applications.
I want to take a look at this era a little
bit, or this new paradigm, a little bit in
more detail to talk about, you know,
what is that we should be thinking about, you
know. Let's
talk about experience frameworks, right? How,
reflect on your typical workday,
how do you do work, right? And you
will see that your work is dominated
by
create, edit, edit, edit, edit
loops.
You edit a lot,
you know. How is that gonna
change?
I believe these loops get changed
from edit, edit, edit
to create and review loops
where the experience has to
be optimized for shortening the
time it takes for you to review
and hand it back to agentic
application for further iterating on the
creation of that content.
What does it really mean on how you
shape the digital workplace?
If you look at traditional operating systems, they
were really optimized for the former,
which is edit, edit, edit,
you know, and the entire UI framework
that the operating, the legacy operating systems
built was to give you a familiar
framework on the edit functionality
across different
UI applications.
The, but the new experience frameworks
are gonna focus on, if you see
kind of the animation,
what is that square box
which the agents and the humans
use to access these applications?
Is it a traditional operating system-based
desktop?
I think newer patterns are going to emerge
where
the experience
and the collection of those applications is
influenced by shortening the review
loops, not by the
legacy UI framework of operating
systems.
While that transition happens, in-app
agents are going to continue filling the gap,
which is
while
you think about the adoption of bonogentic
applications, these in-app agents
continue helping you utilize
the UIs that you're already invested
in and still accelerate your work.
So the first thing we talk about here is
about the new experience frameworks.
What is the future of work
or a future digital workplace,
how you should be thinking about the experience of
that, you can actively shape it. It's
not where the legacy UI framework
of operating systems, new experience
frameworks are going to emerge.
And
the acceleration
to agentic applications, which I
call the right shift,
right, from native applications
to SASS applications to agentic
applications, we see very,
very fast. Transition,
right? Like you see like in-app agents, agentic
applications, different modes of agentic
usage, uh, you know, happening,
and many of the organizations are actually
completely skipping the SAS,
uh, modernizations and skipping
from native to agentic applications.
I think that there are,
there are two or three key points to make here on
how this acceleration itself leverages
agentic AI.
Many of the times, organizations don't
step into a modernization journey because
they think that I have 20 million lines of
code in my native application, right?
Like, and it's gonna take me a decade to modernize
it. I think a lot
of that fear is fueled
by lack of precise
understanding of how your end users are using
that application, right? Like, and we
are gonna give deep visibility to you
to understand the sweet spot,
the 80/20, or, you know, what is
the 20% of the feature set that 80%
of your end users are using, and what are the features and
capabilities that users don't care about, that you
don't have to port,
right? And
You talked about AWS, uh, Matt
talked about AWS Transform in his
uh keynote that it enables
5 up to 5X pace
of uh modernization
of uh typical Windows
applications, right? So with deep visibility
into usage patterns
and agentic applications like AWS
Transform that understand your code base,
you can really, really curate a strategy, and
then you will see uh
kind of more offerings and products from outside.
So,
all of this is good, but what does it
what does it mean for boosted productivity
of your end users?
And that means today, what, what it can
do for you today, right? Like it's
like it's not a theoretical concept. You
You heard Matt introduce Frontier
agents,
Kiiro Autonomous agent,
AWS security agent, and AWS
DevOps agents.
Right? We call them frontier agents because
they are,
they're not typical agents. They have deep
understanding. They are even beyond the research
agents to kind of pick up the lexicon of
uh uh agentic AI,
you know. But
what is next? What is the next in
line of frontier agents that like, you know, AWS
and Workspaces are gonna work, work on?
An admin-focused agent that
helps you pick the right flavor of the product,
helps you onboard to the workspace's service,
helps you manage the workload,
helps you optimize the workload, both
from a cost and performance perspective,
and it's able to take actions on your
behalf,
right? Many of you have actually
seen demos of it. If you had an ABC
with us earlier this week, we have shown
you demos of all these three capabilities,
experience frameworks.
boosted productivity, as well
as kind of transformation journey,
right. Um,
so, if you haven't seen the demo,
please ping your point of contact with
the workspaces or end user computing
services on AWS
and we'll like, we'll love to get in touch with you, give
you a sneak preview and take input from you.
Continuing on this,
you know, what is next in the line of frontier
agents, right? Like we talk about computer
use a lot. Computer use
capabilities, they apply to SAS
applications. But how do we really,
really enable
the thick applications to move fast
and act like agentic applications as well,
right? There's gonna be a
new.
There's going to be a new flavor of computer use
which is built for thick applications, which
enables
these agents to work
on your behalf as an
assistant
or as a teammate,
you know, working on these remote
thick applications and completely automating
your business workflows. This is also one
of the demos that is available to you, you know,
so please ping us.
So,
new experience frameworks,
accelerated right shift
towards agentic applications, boosted
productivity,
you know, what does it really
mean for the choices that you
have to make?
I believe there should at least be one pilot
that you're running or need
to run, which is pure, which is
free from the legacy choices that you
have made or you have
had to make,
you know, and, uh, working
with your leaders, you should be looking to
invest in this pure pilot and expanding
it because
I believe your leadership is also starting
to believe in the kind of, you know, uh,
the agentic AI and how it's gonna help,
you know, make your organizations more nimble.
I will end by saying
that you can choose to retrofit your legacy
choices 365 days of the year.
Or you can choose to reinvent,
you know, and we'll be with you
every day of the week, every
day of the year, working alongside
with you.
Thanks for your time. We appreciate you
coming in
and uh
love chatting with all of you.
We still have some time left in the hour. I
think we can take some questions and I'll still
be around along with the other speakers
to, to have a conversation with you.
Thank you.